ça y est je l'ai
donc là Mathieu on a pris la voiture
pendant trois heures j'ai l'impression
qu'on est un peu monté en altitude
qu'est-ce qu'on vient faire ici alors
oui effectivement on est à 1500 mètres
d'altitude pratiquement dans une zone
fabuleuse pour les papillons ou vol deux
morceaux spectaculaires un qui est bleu
métallique et l'autre qui est plutôt
blanc et on est venu ici pour essayer de
trouver une femelle pour la faire pondre
et pour pouvoir relâcher ses papillons
dans des endroits où elles ont un peu
disparu donc on attrapera qu'une seule
femelle on la gardera environ une
semaine et on l'a relâchera pour qu'elle
puisse continuer à vivre sa vie de
papillon c'est une nos chances à combien
de pourcentage de trouver c'est très
facile de trouver des mâles mais la
femelle c'est compliqué d'accord donc je
dirais
10%. ah ouais ouais mais on est à la
bonne période puisqu'on est au début du
mois de mai et c'est vraiment la bonne
époque pour les papillons si le temps se
découvre un peu ce qui est pas fréquent
ici ça va nous aider
[Musique]
alors du coup là on a préparé les appâts
est-ce que tu peux nous dire ce qu'il y
a dans chacun des deux sauts alors ici
on a les fruits fermentés mélange de
bananes et de goyave on les met dans des
petites poches comme ça ça va se suinter
on va accrocher cette préparation à un
arbre alors c'est surtout pour les
femelles de papillon c'est quoi c'est
l'odeur du coup qui va les attirer c'est
les sels minéraux mais évidemment
l'odeur il la sentent comme nous
et alors là on a une autre mixture un
peu plus compliquée principe la première
fois quand on n'a jamais senti ça on a
un mouvement de recul c'est donc un
mélange de poisson pourri et d'urine ça
sent très très fort et bon c'est c'est
impossible
oh la vache ça se fait des semaines à
l'avance quand même ça c'est pas du jour
pour le moment donc là il faut que je
mette sur des feuilles de préférence
lisse et grande cette mixture qui va
elle plutôt attirer les mâles
surtout on ne gâche pas ce nectar donc
là on a placé un appât ça peut attirer
les papillons qui sont à combien de
mètres 10 15 mètres quand les papillons
vont commencer à se sentir l'odeur ils
vont être attirés alors ça marche
surtout s'il y a du soleil donc on
espère que le soleil va arriver ici
c'est jamais gagné mais je généralement
vers midi il y a une petite éclaircie en
chauffant ça va diffuser l'odeur et ça
devrait attirer nos papillons d'accord
donc 10 15 mètres pas plus ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on ait quand même
relativement de la chance pour essayer
d'attraper le c'est pour ça qu'on en met
un petit peu partout parce qu'on va en
mettre sur tout le bord de la rivière
c'est pas anodin c'est un t-shirt bleu
c'est ça alors tout à fait parce qu'en
fait je vais attirer les morceaux vers
moi ça permettra de mieux les observer
ok bon bah allons-y
[Musique]
voilà Mathieu et moi on s'est séparés
chacun de son côté avec un filet et un
leurre amorpho donc ce petit papier
métallique bleu et on va essayer
d'attraper le morfon à ma tante avec les
papillons sont soit sur la canopée et
descendent près du sol quand il y a des
espaces un peu ouverts donc c'est le
meilleur endroit pour pouvoir les
observer
[Musique]
ça y est je l'ai
ah c'est pas tout à fait celui que
j'espérais parce qu'on a deux morphe ici
celui-ci est le Morpho
péléides et j'espérais prendre un
morphoie ma tante mais bon c'est normal
il est plus commun c'est un mâle ou une
femelle
alors écoute on va le on va le relâcher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce jour là pas de chance nous repartons
sans le fameux morceau à ma tante
Mathieu de golem ne lâchera rien et
retentera sa chance pour essayer
d'attraper une femelle grâce à ses œufs
il pourra espérer repeupler sa forêt de
ce magnifique papillon
[Musique]
ah ouais ah c'est un point là ça fait 88
pour moi 89 pour moi
et là effectivement 88 c'est à dire
qu'en fait là le 89 est super bien
dessiné
[Musique]